after twentieth Century Fox's final
attempt to revive the Fantastic Four for
a feature film failed miserably news of
Marvel Studios plans to do their own
Fantastic Four movie was warmly received
to say the least and now there are
rumors flying about that the team's big
screen comeback could introduce a
seriously powerful comic-book character
we got this covered is reporting that
Disney and Marvel are considering
introducing the mighty mutant Franklin
Richards to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe through their forthcoming
Fantastic Four reboot now it's important
to take this with a grain of salt we got
this covered didn't provide really
anything to substantiate this rumor and
the website has proved less than
reliable in the past but a who can
resist a little fantastic speculation
every now and then described by the site
as the most powerful superhero to ever
appear in Marvel Comics Franklin
Richards is the child of the Fantastic
Four's iconic couple Sue Storm and Reed
Richards the Richards famously developed
their superhuman powers after being
exposed to cosmic radiation during a
spaceflight expedition but their son
obtained his powers at birth created by
comics legends Jack Kirby and Stan Lee
and first appearing in 1968 Fantastic
Four annual issue 6 Franklin was born
after a pregnancy that nearly killed his
mother his genetic structure is altered
like his parents meaning Franklin's
superhuman powers manifested fast and
furiously in the vein of his fellow
omega-level mutant Franklin's full power
registers beyond any definable limit in
fact his capabilities are so impressive
that he's even compared to Marvel's
Celestials a race of humanoid aliens who
came into being around the same time as
the universe itself in the future
Franklin will actually be one of only
two beings around to witness the total
end of the universe Franklin has been a
part of so much throughout the Fantastic
Four's long history in the Marvel
Universe so it's difficult to get a
concrete grasp on how he would fit into
the Fantastic Four reboot any number of
Franklin's iterations could feature in
the forthcoming flick from his early
days and the powerpack
team of kids who possess superhuman
powers to his role in the Human Torch
list future Foundation and a backstory
that rich could easily present a ton of
headaches for Marvel Studios creatives
as they try to figure out a way to
introduce Franklin to the MCU would all
that effort even be worth it it's hard
to say for sure but this is far from the
first time Franklin's been rumored to
appear in a Fantastic Four film in June
2017 Fox reportedly considered bringing
Franklin Richards into the live-action
sphere
according to bleeding cool there were
rumors that Fox was eyeing a possible
kid centric film set in the Fantastic
Four universe that featured Franklin and
his younger sister Valyria along with
appearances by the thing and the Human
Torch those rumors resurfaced in July
2017 around the time that it was
announced that Legion showrunner Noah
Hawley had a Doctor Doom film and
development and while Fox seemed more
than happy to forget about the entire
2015 Fantastic Four reboot debacle it
did appear that the studio was
interested in mining the heroes
considerable cinematic universe
potential now that Fox and Disney have
merged it's likely that Disney has
scrapped Fox's previous plans for any
Fantastic Four adjacent characters in
favor of their own on the flip side the
studio convergence has apparently paved
the way to reboot heaven with Disney CEO
Bob Iger already confirming that Fox
properties such as Home Alone & Night at
the Museum will take on a new life at
Disney Plus Disney is clearly invested
in expanding its family centric
narratives and though the Fantastic Four
franchise will probably fall into line
with the rest of the MCU Franklin's
rumored arrival could open up the chance
for more of a family focused superhero
team-up at the end of the day though
this is all just talk until Marvel comes
forward with concrete information about
the new Fantastic Four movie all fans
can do is speculate on what the future
might hold check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belts so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]